Ok well. It's monday monday night or not it's there and then he says. I'm danny's able. And i'm i.
Very good at visual presentations you know upon nine hundred and using my bodily movements. To express and.
I'm here in him then working to help the. Korea's. Twentieth anniversary. Form into some sort of. Good energy.
Those are my entities. You know i have sort of formed a number of characters.
Well after the aquarius festival in seventy three. There was a lot of people. Around with the.
Entities and interesting the entities and. I transform benny's able into design the bubbles.
From just transposing the bin there's a and. And any case i was doing bubble the images the bubbles.
Form of expression. Then i was great does or in company was of the actual.
Came out and it sort of developed in the ids. You know any idea on. When i got involved. You know i decided to take my.
More skills into the activist. Forum. And have and develop this character. For the for the movement.
Bit of a shock shock. Image. Well the great dozer and company.
And it sort of got known as a dollar man because as if the great doze of flesh is the dollar
and seem to be into dollars. Destroying the environment with a dollar or using the dollar as a. As a weapon. Again.
This is so i came here. He nine hundred seventy three. With a performance troupe we called ourselves the.
The cost of coffee and i'm there the metaphysical magic and i would call this a metaphysical metal chair
and we came with a performance. On the wells which we. Trumped up.
It was a time machine we tramped it up into sort of like the mechanical people. And the beautiful people.
You know sort of the mechanical and the people in a more free spirit living on the earth.
And you had the mechanical people the van of the good which was a sort of split of height you wealth of have a society
will split in the future. And out of sight of the plight of time travel. Is it and when we sort of.
It was very interesting it sort of really worked because it was very fitting. To the environment. But when i came here.
After props. Ended up taking off to sea bryza been we were asked in the field there and we setting up a sort of.
Spot and i ended up doing dance workshops every morning in the main town hall for through up and then we.
Towards the end of the festival we had to weigh a prop stand we did our performance. I would just sort of. You know.
The group of us just went around just did things all around for so much going on you just sort of participate
and just become more free form and in participating. Around the. This the area around the site area.
And participating in forums and. Writing with the different bands and getting with other people doing things.
Well the highlight was doing the performance. It was quite. Mr mysterious event.
The acoustic was in the year in the bush factory before was the bush fact it was all the scaffolding. Set up.
And i remember we had the screen up there and. And i was i used the scaffolding to get these dramatic sounds and.
It just sort of created these dramatic samples we had these had this sort of beautiful white garments with feet turned
around was blackened and skulls.
In there and so we had to sort of contrast the images of this is of just really lawit characters and then.
Them with a large show we had. Tom power doing. Poetry right if you know tom.
And he was doing sort of a sort of free form.
Poetry interludes to interact with the with the people in and telling them the story of the time.
Machine so was was semi. We used the script as a sort of improvise to improvise on. And sometimes the movements.
So it was all that sort of hanging out on the on that and. And interacting with people with fruit you know.
Calling it would bowls of fruit. And with that with the the loiters of beautiful people and then.
There are some angelic i was the execution that sort of chopping off people's heads you know with these magic.
In terms of. You know we're doing the the. The mechanical stuff and so was the processing going in.
It was very interesting because at that place the bush fact he was a mate works to. And you know later dies and.
He would not synergy there. Still got nice energy today. All the bush radio here was set up by a whole group.
Combined group of people. Which was which just.
From the universities the universities were just getting into sort of puerto pacs. I mean puerto pacs and then.
Interacting with the community.
On issues where people can type the types out
and people can go out there mike mike mike their own video what's a random and. Get feedback and just.
Was sort of the that process just came on that on the market so called group came up here
and decided to set up i set up a whole network with within the live with the cable link up for the sot just ideas and.
And just developing their technology as a sort of an internal monitoring of what's going on people went out in the
field and took it up put a pex and. Video type what i wanted them. You know and.
And then brought it back and that was shown to have people. People just look at it. And so yeah well i just saw.
It was all done by young people who never didn't know how bad it is just sort of they're learning about it and lot of.
And even people within the field are just learning about had to handle this. This equipment and. So it's and squatter.
You know. Having them.
It's quite expensive to our member that had one heart it was a birthing that took place on the at the.
And at the first i saw that i was quite incredible. Actually a birth at the. Aquarius festival was actually.
Monitored back from the day before. To people. Just the whole thing was that it was quite a culture shock for me.
But that was that was that was one of the things it was a hamas and it was on on the on the on the. The box around.
Special. Postings around town. Well you had different stages for one. You know dollar brand.
Was a hot one of the highlights he was doing music you know you could be doing. Long stints of piano applying.
Really being from south africa.
It was great and i used to go down and dance and do interact with dance with people
and get these things happening with him develop these sort of things that was part of my thing it was not only was i
dance. You know. Trying dancer turned into. You know freeing up the form.
But i developed in that form through the melbourne. Early stages in melbourne.
In the in that sort of light sixty's and seventy's and interact with bands
and sort of become a cat i used as a sort of a catalyst. A form of catalyst to together.
There was a nine like i developed a name for it was sort of like a crowd. A crowd.
Stimulator some of that a crowd of us and i got beat i had.
I was doing things the disco is where i'll be on stage and i'll go up and do things and so congo lines and.
Little groups dancing and writing as a sort of just toy. You know ends up so there's a focus. So you so you.
So you take. Take the whole dance thing.
Into wrecked the dance thing so you get these groups things happening with bands. Of people.
And the other things are just other things that took place during the day things was just.
There was also philip to eat during these high wind up that really was a my thing. And it was the writing for. I.e.
Sort of just you know put up. You just sort of. Coming with a unicycle on your string up.
You know it's just this thing.
Thing guy with a black hat he was dressed in black with tiles and that you know just coming in
and your drawer this law i mean you know. Any staff. Doing this thing with the. First of all the clearly.
The spice by using a unicycle to create a space and i just and draw the line around.
Did all the sort of traditional french. Sort of mind. Type sequences.
So you get to committee i was no voice it was just my man.
And he had these juggling all this sort of things that's pretty much in vogue with with. Street performers.
There of which he was a sort of. He brought it.
Pretty fresh into this country wasn't going to know was probably was probably the first straight performer. Doing it.
Yeah. You know a strike. Because it was pretty much like.
It was a strain saying he had to go through some strange scenes here because it was pretty much.
The authorities wouldn't allow him to do the sort of things that wasn't there wasn't a forum for bass things have to be
battled down the track. To win. You know getting by laws passed that people could do these things.
But at first he just sort of like the queries first it was a good forum for him to try this have seen was an eye open
for open. Social forum. To try out new ideas and street theatre.
In many forms were taking place not only just for the potato but he used to string up the wire
and he did that in a big. In the pub in mid to madison and you know.
This sort of tomato soup which the neighborhood sent to your center now and used to do the thing then just go
and how is just amazing it just did these things and he had to prepare taishan of. Of string up the the high wire.
On the not in high places around the world leaks and he did. When he went to sydney tried it did it on the.
Sydney harbor and i saw they start the take down he's right. When he was up there the authorities freaked.
It was really dangerous he was sort of like the way actually i'm doing the right when he was up there
and see these things. And i think it's pretty dangerous thing to do.
But he was he was a highlight for me sort of just observing him and there was fred robinson
and he's your rant you're right if you notice there's a whole new i g o of this whole connection.
You knew i had sort of thinking so. Around. I was the food. You know that i sort of. Trust food thing in the food.
Kitchen was all that sort of. Cooperate. You know people. On trust and cooperation. The whole. Festival was based on.
Just allowing any of us the shitters like there's a whole things that i was quite think i was one of the first it was.
Well first i'm live i'm into a fist a way where way. Everybody just was in a circle.
In any shape in a circle like you know and all had this circle and you know it was all hope
and there was sort of makes you know as you know i was no. Sort of sick. Sexual sort of.
Division everybody came in there and. Just come pasta the spot on the floor and you become ill. You know i was a whole.
Awareness of you know. I was very good because as they become aware of your own. Bodily functions and.
Broke down a lot of missed. Myths from living in the city. And i was there was another good seeing and.
And there was the song warners and my own sort of these things that are. And just me.
And the bamboo bridges across the creek was with form of this that all these things all these hats
and things that were built out of all of these diverse the writing. I write of. The wellings that we've put up.
And and remember as theater group. Developed.
And as sort of the well developed wellington you know how you're relating to where it's all so i think it was
interesting because it was pretty. Ratty tatty thing you know. But it was sort of.
You know going to bend it for you but we said that it was a place where we got on there was a plastic and.
And bamboo and stuff. And it kept that. And there was it was sheltered. And we had a shelter up. You can not.
I came to nimbin as well like a cat.
Our life just came down with this with the trip to be part of this festival because i was at festivals like.
It's not the first festival i went to. I was part of the sort of.
Festival drifts like ten alone and not before i was in town when i was pong. And and. In victoria we had.
Was it was sun brain yes it was the sun breeze and.
The one before that i think kathy was lying but there was a few of these sort of events and also being part of.
You know. Indoor events. With much more boredom and. My will that's called sort of into media. Get togethers. And.
So yeah. So there was there was that connection. And that's what i. Got here it's just just widen the hole.
You know what. What festivals. Can do. Like festivals we're actually setting up. Social. You know.
He really can learn from festivals a lot. I mean these days that.
You learn about society as aziz and people learn there and they can change they can learn to change
but you just set up experiments and it's funny temporary i mean it's something that's going to be temporary but.
You can really go forward. And just do it as a as a marker scope on ideas with everybody.
I started on because then it was the. The idea of state of getting a community. Well getting.
Probably many for many reasons to get a hold of it probably so that the people that i hear.
Have a place where they can keep their ideas going like develop their ideas from their experience from the aquarius
festival. And people had different ideas like that the total commune idea of.
Like a way of living here during the a chris festival forming this.
This site where we all care and share and do everything. So you know get some probably and try and do that and it was.
It was that sort of idealistic. Idealism that was around at the time and also very poor people. You know. Very poor.
We had to work something here we do it and. And also people that had dropped out. As such and.
And were shot in the pond in different ways because they were. Not part of the status quo in.
Types
and it was students as well because there was this disillusionment there's a lot of social reasons why this of second
place the disillusionment with the whole. Was this. With the war with the war mentality and. And this the whole.
Philosophical discussion about that as. That you towards. You know we had real social problems. To sort out.
And let alone. The. The earth and getting back to the guy in the sort of was the sort of spinoff from woodstock.
Itself life as well. And that that was it that had a big impact on me you know like woodstock itself.
And i guess a lot of people here i think that's as it was a human thing and this.
This became this sort of a stray as woodstock. That's have turned out to be other.
I don't know who was intentionally but it was. What the university setting him on.
You know was going to be a would still. But it. It was that because. Woodstock was also.
When i was i ever in america discovered that. And reading about.
That was the same thing was going on there was that disillusionment and. And this that all these philosophers and.
Writers and musicians and trying to express a different world from the world of of. Of competitive. Smashing and.
Pushing and killing and writing. To something that's. That gets back to the earth and gentle caring.
All that sort of all those sort of. That sort of society. Develop a society.
In that sort of winds and i give him the name aquarius. This how did that. Progress.
Well we just have to work on our ideas and i mean it's so it's.
To me it's been successful because it's successful as much energy of. What people have discovered. And certain.
There's a lot of what. What has been experimented on is to self into the mainstream. Like the mainstream just takes.
The cream of ideas. That really you know that they see can work with mainstream and. You know you.
Have alternative healing process is the health. Health food. That you carry an ism. That has been advanced.
From that sort of thinking. The whole of these different. Co-ops. That around the place. You know. And the war.
Now listen less people. Getting away from thinking about that fighting and finding solutions to.
Conflict resolution and. It is quite you know it's just a lot of. And just in the health and healing.
Aspect as hades in the perma culture and that's developed but it sort of grew out of that. Interest in the earth and.
An alternative. Thing. Seems of internal. To monaco.
Culture that some people living on the earth here are realizing that monoculture is destroying the earth.
But it's just part of that thinking that's that lateral thinking it's not that there's not that sort of level way where
you think that as a society. We could this is the why. It is is the way it can't be changed from there.
Because the opposite society but actual fact that you use.
That there is a role for for dropping out and trying out ideas as part of the. Creative artists.
Role of taking on that role. So it's all eyes on our. I enjoy. That whole investigation the seeking role.
And the funders. That's a real. It's not. Not new it's not even move. Aquarius was just a time.
That sort of just highlight it i mean that's goes on throughout the ages see if you look back.
He really getting into the interior is that you have this sort of.
Line of thinking that goes right back in time here since. In humans or upon this earth this sort of thing that.
That development has created the world we were in. Sort of civil. Civilized nation all.
Thing is just part of the concepts that came up. People to try and.
You know this sort of that somehow we live with the earth and. The creatures around us.
And then we have all these problems and then we're going to solve these problems so it needs.
Certain things and you have different. And communication. You know. Communication the.
Communication chains like you have the you are nice and spirit. Which was a real change now times in relation to the.
That stands out because it was a radical child with technology. Because i was all set to do it makes.
Mixing with technology and. And they never became this sort of technology to rot in that time.
The printing press and the. Building a whole lot of. You know. Architecture building. In temples.
And it was a sort of european sort of connection going on this sort of internationalisation. Happening. So the post.
Post. Roman empire times. And sort of. Coming out of the middle ages. Incident this.
Coming out of the void said that there was that there was a sort of a period that sort of.
And a spiritual awakening and this also spirituality is part of a process.
That's something else that's that's found here in him been that there was investigation into alternative spirituality
there was a dissolution of krista due to day made by simply who we've. The people that came to this.
What people from that sort of you guy christian background.
And of quite disillusioned because that sort of really created. That world that. That we rebelled against.
And sort of was. Which sort of related to. Punishment and guilt and all that and was sort of.
Free ourselves off from that. And with us. You had a christian is he also vegetarianism.
The christians were part of that sort of culture that. There was around there. And there was a way here. In terms of.
That brought their culture their culture here and it was all caught on now i have spiritual groups and sort of new age.
Christian groups as well sort of. And in buddhism and. Buddhism took off quite strong. After you chris first of all.
It's a very kind of quite a strong thing as and it was in my direction. I mean. Not everybody become a buddhist but.
I had a very strong had a big impact on my life is is being able to sit and observe. In a life. You know.
You know activity. And become aware. In that shop in my awareness. Still point. And yoga. That sort of bodily.
I think you know yoga in touch all these things that you could do way up here in this special place this place just
turned out to be. So special with the rocks in the valley. You just create a special.
There's a certain energy about this place and then there's the aboriginal. Connection with this place and.
A lot of things that just the mystery of this place is something special about me i mean.
I kept my finger on i don't know of anyone. Previous put the thing but a certainly has a magical it sort of that.
It creates inspiration. Yeah yeah there are yes. Yes. It's good coming back to the place and see the that.
The place is not being very radically altered even though i was sort of fearing there's going to be radical alterations
coming up. And there. But it's also that there is that there's a. There's this. It's this people this.
All these hard thing connections are still there. He she.
If you look forward it's around all those other connections with all that accrue stuff that happened during the korea's
first of all is is a rare. You know it's. In the area. Yes..
Oh oh oh well this is a model artistic google doodle or sexually it's a sort of self-seeking. And then x.
Externalizing it. In terms of design the bubbles are. Well as i knew bubbles sort of grew out of the.
Well after the aquarius first of all. I just decided to change. You know create this character.
Before that i had a red. Pair of tights. And you know us i just had just ordinary tarts and dance things and and.
You know the time traveler. Was pretty much in costumes and terms of.
There was just a part of the performance
but now i wanted to do it as an environmental piece by going to expand my ideas. And also as a clam character and.
Because it was sort of a community now. It's just one expanded that i just just came to my he had just an idea. And.
So i just started developing and. But it was in the sixty's. Was was in early seventy's.
Sunni sunni while after sixty nine because i was overseas six and sixty nine and. Started to.
I did a series of paintings which were on the bubble and would sort of drift. Bubbles drifting through voids and and.
Out of flying into. Crevices and coming out of clouds and. And there and going through a maybe is.
Is just and different getting into spirals and. Just the dots. Getting into all these sort of other images.
And you have to look at it like i just created this whole. Working with with. With time and spices. And shipe and and.
Just exploring it. And just from that's a round hole.
And if i draw in the round or mean i sort of get into that meditation of doing. Circles. Very simple.
And just the ideas spinning off. One after the other. As i did a series of campuses in melbourne big. Campuses and.
They never really. Completed. Because completely because i was part of a community. At the cannery i asked santa.
We started a group of us. Broke away from the pram factory in. Calton saying he wanted to start something. Away.
But it sort of got. Lumbered with the council. Sort of. Really you know because it was so.
It was you know sort of a rich sea area. They couldn't hack us you know i was right there in in. In the electorate of.
Of. Prime minister of the time. Yeah. One of the prime ministers and so you know it was sort of. It sort of.
Was a whole lot of ripping.
You know sort of blocks and clothes that got more expensive
and the council wanted to do with this big theatre down into something else.
And it was that of the residence groups there. And for the saif.
It's a very the that that whole is to beautiful buildings they're the old buildings.
That's another story that i was into that to you about is the hard rock stuff that was in child not the time i mean you
saw the paintings of all building a song the old. Environment. There was a stuff.
So you know i lost my son so i thought oh well from that story.
So well so you know well that beppe developed later on and so desire new bubbles was the character.
But i didn't plan to paint shop fronts and even with that it's just that i had that and i. And i i had.
I didn't i was seven years later when i came to me and been. And i was designing bubbles at the time. And.
And graeme danson actually wrote write to me in melbourne. Also spending six months down here. Up here.
Put put money into i have exhibitions than i did. All buildings and places. And workshops in melbourne.
As i had the whole connection. Family connections in melbourne. And. And relationships and that sort of thing.
It was all. Phantom album. And then i came up here to develop. The ideas in this sort of social.
Experimental you know get together which can even.